hey 42 here I think we can all agree
that dogs are amazing creatures smart
loving and loyal there's a reason we
consider canines not chickens to be
man's best friend
and if there's a lesson to learn from
watching glassy other than the fact that
some humans can understand how yet
another bastard bark translates to
Timmy's trapped in a mine it's that dogs
are also Brave oh and as an interesting
Mandela effect aside not once in 571
episodes did Timmy ever get trapped down
a well
anyway it stands to reason that the
Accolade of Bravest dog in history is
hotly contested despite many contenders
for this coveted canine Crown one dog
climbed Head and Shoulders Above the
Rest
the dogs have shoulders can we check
that during the darkest days in modern
history this was a dog who led from the
front fighting for his country while
most dogs were content to cowardly stay
at home asleep in their baskets which is
fair enough I guess they were dogs after
all meanwhile this proud Pooch served in
17 battles was given his own rank in the
Army and even long after he passed is
still seen by millions of people every
year
I know that last bit sounds strange but
trust me
say hello to Sergeant Stubby the most
decorated dog of the first world war and
an inspiration to humans and animals
alike
[Music]
now let's take a minute to talk about
hair loss because I've had people close
to me start to lose their hair as early
as their 20s and it's always been an
upsetting experience
if you're in the same boat then you're
not alone did you know two out of three
guys will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
but the best thing you can do to prevent
hair loss is take the initiative now
do something about it whilst you've
still got hair left I like keeps because
it makes treatment super easy by
delivering your hair loss medication
every three months so you can say
goodbye to awkward doctor visits and
waiting in Pharmacy checkout lines
there's a reason that keeps has more 5
Star reviews than any of its competitors
and hundreds of thousands of men trust
them for their hair loss prevention
medication so if you're like me you're
probably not ready to lose your hair
just yet but prevention is key the
faster you act the faster you'll see
results and the sooner you start using
keeps the more hair you'll save if
you're noticing that you're losing your
hair do something about it for a limited
time go to keeps.com 42 or click the
link in the description below to receive
50 off your first order thanks to keeps
for sponsoring this video the phenomenon
of animals in action is nothing new if
you went back 2 000 years you'd witness
war elephants wreaking havoc on Ancient
battlefields and since then several
species have served their Mass just in a
skirmish from Camels and pigeons to rats
and dolphins this veritable Noah's Ark
of beasts in battle
naturally dogs have featured most
prominently over time because of their
intelligence temperament and proclivity
to obey
the Romans trained dogs to fight by
their side and you might remember the
opening battle scene in Gladiator where
Russell Crowe's four-legged friend
fights off his foes
in the Middle Ages hunting dogs like
Mastiffs were sent into battle to topple
knights from their horses and Beaufort
Hilla the Hun and Napoleon counted dogs
amongst their forces
in the Boer War several dogs earned
medals after serving British regiments
in South Africa
so by the time the first world war broke
in 1914 there was already a long
tradition of dogs and Duty
little is known about Stubby's early
years the Plucky five-year-old Boston
Terrier was first found roaming the
grounds of Yale University in July 1917.
at the time the 102nd infantry 26th
division was based at the Yale Bowl the
University's football stadium and stubby
would hang around as they trained
one soldier in particular took a shine
to this errant mutt a private by the
name of James Conroy and he named him
stubby because of his short tail the
dogs that is not Conroy's the newly
christened stubby appeared made for life
in the military and he practiced the
required drills and bugle calls along
with the other soldiers
the camp rules forbade animals but
stubby had such a positive effect on
morale that the rules were swayed he
even learned how to do a little Dougie's
salute raising his right paw to his
eyebrow on command
after three months of training the 26
division were deployed to the front line
in France
now Conroy had a dilemma since he wasn't
technically allowed to bring his new
best mate along but as he saw it leaving
him on campus was just plain wrong
so when the regiment rode the train to a
Virginia Port stubby joins them from
there Conroy smuggled stubby aboard the
SS Minnesota by hiding him under his
great coat thankfully stubby was a tiny
Terrier not a great day
once on board Conroy concealed stubby in
a coal bin which is a humiliating way
for anyone to travel transatlantic
especially a future war hero
mid-journey Stubby's Destiny turns dicey
when he was discovered by an officer
Legend has it the Hound won the
gentleman round by doing his patented
salute
Charmed by his doggy deference it was
decided he could stay
free from his Hideaway he roamed the
ship as the crew grew fond of this
Superstar stowaway he was so endearing
that a machinist made him a set of
literal dog attacks and the 122nd
division declared him as their
unofficial mascot
the SS Minnesota landed at San Nazir on
the western coast of France shortly
after the troops plus one Pooch traveled
to the Western Front a 400-mile stretch
of trenches bordering France and Belgium
at first stubby had no official role but
joined Conroy in his various duties
occasionally accompanying him on
Horseback as he ferried messages to
various command posts but it was in
February 1918 that stubby truly turned
into a dog of war on St Patrick's Day
the front line where he and his master
were bunkered came under intense
bombardment from Germans who shelled it
non-stop for 24 hours
soon after stubby was exposed to toxic
gas and had to be taken to a field
hospital and nursed back to health
but this incident imbued him with a
canine superpower from then on his nose
was highly sensitive to any traces of
gas hopefully excluding any that came
from his own ass
using his newly found olfactory
Excellence stubby soon committed his
first truly heroic act early one morning
the Germans launched a gas attack and
stubby smelt it long before his human
companions even knew who dealt it he
proceeded to dash up and down the trench
barking and nipping at the soldiers to
wake them and ushered them to safety
for his bravery stubby was made a
private first class oh and if you were
concerned for Stubby's safety during his
gas detection duties fear not his
comrades had fashioned him a custom gas
mask
by now stubby drew a distinctive figure
sporting a specially made Chamois coat
reportedly given to him by admiring
local women
it was embroidered with his name and
became home to his ever-growing
collection of medals one commendable
Consignment of stubbies was seeking out
wounded soldiers in no man's land he
would pinpoint his allies in Need by
listening out for English speech then
he'd bound over and stand by them
barking to alert the paramedics
once back in the Dugout stubby sat
beside the wounded men keeping them
company and he remained awake if they
fell asleep to ensure they were safe
sadly stubby sustained a war wound
during an especially Fierce German
attack when trapnil hit him in his leg
and chest
but you can't keep a good dog down and
after a couple of months of rest he was
back doing what he did best putting the
fear of God or should that be dug into
the Enemy by now he was able to identify
Germans and Americans by their uniforms
Kaki meant good and gray meant bad
one day he spotted a German spy hiding
in some bushes seemingly trying to map
out the Allied trenches well Nissan's
Stubby's watch he charged the Insurgent
sinking his teeth in and holding on
until the Cavalry arrived well infantry
in this case for this courageous act
stubby was made a sergeant as a bonus an
iron cross was lifted from the captured
German and placed on Stubby's coat for
him to keep
Stubby's dislike of the second Reich was
so strong that when prisoners of War
were brought back to Camp he had to be
tied up so he didn't further add to
their woes by gnawing at their toes
stubby remained at the heart of the
action until the war ended in November
1918. by then the 102nd had seen more
fighting than any other American
infantry 210 days in total
to say they must have been dog tired
he's putting it mildly when his unit
relocated to Paris stubby was
purportedly recognized by hundreds of
American Australian French and English
troops eager to shake his paw and he
even led a Victory Parade in the city
too much hurray then on Christmas day he
met President Woodrow Wilson the first
of three he would encounter
stubby promptly presented his paw to the
POTUS for a shake apparently the
formality of his usual salute went out
the window when he was meeting Ward
leaders bit rude
in April of 1919 stubby and Conroy were
officially demobilized back in
Massachusetts but whilst the war was
over for stubby things were just getting
started he'd arrived in France in 1917
an anonymous animal
and he returned a year later a K-9
Superstar he was like Scooby-Doo but a
Really Brave Scooby-Doo that could sniff
out gas and wasn't weirdly obsessed with
snacks he traveled across America to
Veterans commemorations and was hounded
by the paparazzi or should that be
paparazzi
sorry I'll stop now are much lauded
Mongrel even became a vordville star
performing in Theaters owned by the
biggest impresario of the day the
wonderfully named Sylvester Z poly and
he once appeared on stage with the
so-called queen of movies Mary Pickford
the most famous actress of the age
stubby was now the most celebrated
animal in America and there was no end
in sight for his ever greater escapades
in 1920 he appeared at the Republican
National Convention then in 1921 he was
awarded a gold medal at the White House
by General John Pershing the highest
ranking officer in the U.S army
that same year James Conroy remember him
Stubby's owner the guy with the big coat
yeah
moved to Washington to study law at the
prestigious Georgetown University never
one to Simply sit about stubby became
the University's Sports mascot during
football games at half time he'd keep
the crowds and thralls by playing with
the ball when not Kipping at the
University he enjoyed many alternative
accommodations The Majestic Hotel in New
York one of the finest of the era built
by Jacob Rothschild in Central Park
broke its no dog's policy and allowed
stubby to stay the night
think what was on the room service Bill
the following morning
oh he was also made a lifetime member of
the YMCA which as we all know is a fun
place to stay
and they promised him free bones a day
and a place to sleep whenever he wanted
[Music]
stubby enjoyed his celebrity lifestyle
of parades pictures and plentiful bone
picnics for many years he lived until a
ripe old age of 13. dying peacefully in
his sleep in 1926 and received a
full-length obituary in the New York
Times that opened simply and powerfully
stubby is dead but good old stubby
continued to serve his country even
after death he was taxidermied replete
in his trademark coat and medals and
placed in the Smithsonian Museum where
he remains to this day
every year millions of visitors have the
chance to see stubby as part of an
exhibition on the Great War and it's
nice to know that over 100 years since
His Brilliant bravery on the battlefield
the world is still celebrating the dog
whose bite was every bit as bad as his
bark
oh and it's been confirmed dogs do have
shoulders
good to know
and thanks for watching